the movie begins somewhere in China as a
young woman's car lies Stranded by a
deserted Highway with frustration
mounting and a dead phone she hesitates
when a roughl looking truck driver
offers help however relief washes over
her as a seemingly harmless man and
glasses stops his car to assist in the
car she expresses her gratitude towards
the man in glasses he appears kind and
urges her not to judge the truck driver
solely by his appearance things quickly
turn upside down as she tries to recline
her seat but accidentally touches a cold
bloody hand on the back back seat the C
facade of the man shatters replaced by a
chilling glint in his eyes he Slams on
the brakes transforming from savior to
monster as he brutally murders the girl
with a wrench however in the next scene
we see that this incident is actually
being narrated by a man to a bus driver
who remains skeptical of the story the
bus carrying six passengers is being
driven by driver Kang on the winding
jinpen Highway among the passengers are
salesman mawen tunnel engineer H Shen a
pregnant woman wuu a lady named Tang
zenu who is wearing wearing heavy makeup
and a revealing red dress and teenage
siblings Z and her autistic brother xuu
as they ascend the treacherous road the
radio announces news of a highway
closure due to an accident in a nearby
tunnel urging travelers to take a detour
the bus driver suggests a shortcut and
none of the passengers object to it
their bumpy Journey soon finds them
entering a tunnel carved through a hill
however only a little distance into the
tunnel the driver Slams on the brakes
for a passenger standing in the middle
of the road though unusual he allows the
man chenia to board his bus inside the
tunnel engineer recognizes chenia as a
wanted criminal from a newspaper article
choosing caution he hides a knife nearby
for protection meanwhile the pregnant
wuu frustrated with her husband throws
her phone at the window and tries to
calm her nerves with knitting however
hhen becomes suspicious as he realizes
they've been driving for 20 minutes with
no sign of an exit and no other vehicles
on the road turning back they drive for
another 30 minutes yet the tunnel seems
endless bewildered the driver stops and
argues with the equally confused
passengers suddenly wiu notices her
phone lying on the road and retrieves it
astoundingly she recalls throwing it out
near the tunnel entrance Juju showcases
his sharp mind as he estimates the bus
had traveled nearly 300 M before wuyu
had thrown out her phone H Chen the
engineer confirms the tunnel shouldn't
be longer than 3 kilm but the driver
insists they've driven at least 30
trapped in the endless tunnel the
passengers face an unsettling reality
refusing to believe in Supernatural
forces H Chen suggests measuring the
tunnel's length by walking with a rope
unexpectedly the silent chenia offers
the pregnant woman's knitting yarn for
the task together they Venture into the
depths of the tunnel after walking a
considerable distance the yarn runs out
to their bewilderment they find a used
fishing line lying there despite their
hesitation they tie it to the yarn and
continue their track suddenly an eerie
fog descends upon the tunnel as the
passengers near the bus anxiously await
for the Two Men Tang the lady in red
screams Shadows loom in the fog
approaching from the opposite end to
everyone's shock it's h Chan and chenia
returning to the starting point still
holding the fishing line but the horror
doesn't end there they find a severed
finger attached to the end of the
fishing line which sends chills down
their spines the bus driver Kang
suggests paranormal activity while Tang
speculates about a hallucinogenic drug
causing their nightmarish experience yet
hen insists on being rational determined
to find a scientific explanation for
their endless Journey facing the
possibility of prolonged confinement the
passengers sit down on a table and share
their food Tang's picky eating habit
leads to ma when acquiring an extra
packet of noodles after a small snack
the men Venture back into the tunnel
searching for escape while the women in
Juju rest in the bus upon their return
they find the bus covered in a thick
layer of dust as if the bus had been
sitting there for ages moan adds to the
unsettling Atmosphere by mentioning his
renewed hunger despite having just eaten
the bus driver Kang makes a a horrifying
Discovery the food they stored has
rotted confirming their fear that time
moves faster within the tunnel their
anxieties intensify when Kang fails to
start the boss despite repeated attempts
meanwhile hen finds a map near the front
seat despite clearly remembering that
there was no map when he sat there as a
tunnel engineer he examines the map and
discovers a strange thing while the map
indicates that the tunnel runs in north
south Direction their Compass Points
East West changia quickly looks at his
weird watch which has a timer counting
down from 1 hour 14 minutes beforeand
Shen can elaborate his plan the tunnel
plunges into darkness a blood curdling
scream pierces the night as hand Shen
Falls victim to an unseen attacker when
Kang lights the headlights Shen is gone
replaced by a chilling blood trail on
the floor LED by chenia the terrified
passengers reluctantly follow the trail
which abruptly ends at a wall undeterred
Chen notices a hollow sound and slams a
rod against the wall to everyone's
astonishment a red door swings open
revealing a Dusty room filled with
antique artifacts a television and a
macabra collection newspaper clippings
detailing missing and murdered
individuals including the article hand
Chen was previously reading as everyone
searches the room for food chenia
discovers an engineering blueprint of
the tunnel on a table meanwhile J
stumbles Upon A horrifying display of
five severed hands each missing a ring
finger Kang points out the chilling
connection to the finger found earlier
in the tunnel intensifying Their Fear
studying the map Chen identifies six
other tunnels connected to their current
1 he proposes finding an escape rat
through one of them during their search
they uncover a Calendar displaying only
a single date July 15th carrying down
the calendar reveals a hidden passage as
they cautiously enter the room's
television flickers to life showing a
desperate woman trapped in water
pleading for help emerging from the
passage they find themselves in an
abandoned tunnel Chan and Kang
discreetly discuss mawen and his story
with Chen harboring suspicions about his
involvement in the killings Kang laughs
at the idea dismissing when is too weak
to be a killer suddenly they spot Kang's
bus at a distance however the windows
are shattered and it is surrounded by
barbed wire Kang and mawin rushed
towards the bus discovering a large box
of snacks identical to the one they had
earlier fortunately these snacks are not
rotten to Kang's annoyance maen takes
the snacks outside to share with
everyone enraged by this act Kang grabs
a revolver found near the seat and
storms out claiming the snacks for
himself he ruthlessly shoves everyone
away declaring they are now on their own
driven by hunger Tang returns to the bus
and seduces Kang to share a packet of
noodles as tensions settle Chen
approaches Kang and emphasizes the
urgency of finding an escape as his
timer is slowly beginning to run out of
time he explains that hoarding food is
feudal as it will Decay rapidly due to
the accelerated time within the tunnel
with tension settling down mawen and
Tang searched for an exit in One
Direction while chenia wuyu and the
siblings head the other way Kang remains
near the bus after walking a distance
from the others mawin attempts to force
himself on Tang she retaliates by
kicking him and angrily returns to the
bus informing Kang about the incident
while Kang and Tang are busy making love
mawen steals a packet of noodles from
Kang before mawen can enjoy his stolen
food Kang emerges in a fit of rage
intent on punishing him he throws mawen
to the ground and reaches for a tnd drum
in his Fury just then mawen spots
someone behind Kang but before he can
warn him a steel rod pierces Kang's
abdomen killing him instantly maen
alerts the others and Chaos erupts Tang
accuses maen of murder fueled by the
stolen noodles which he desperately
denies insisting someone else is lurking
in the tunnel he rushes for the bus to
retrieve another packet of food tang
tries to stop him causing a packet to
fall beneath the bus desperate mawen
reaches for the Fallen packet and
discovers a hidden trapo beneath it
combining their strength they push the
bus aside and pry open the trap door
descending one by one they find a
familiar sight a Dusty Red Room
identical to the one with the hid hidden
passage however this time a gruesome
display of four severed ring fingers
each bearing a wedding band replaces the
five hands on the counter wi U
speculates that the culprit targets
married women as before the television
depicts the woman trapped in a waterfill
hole desperately calling for help shaken
they proceed through the hidden passage
emerging on the other side they see a
damp leaky tunnel and they once again
encounter Kang's bus Kang and maen rush
to it hoping for food but find only
snakes and insects suddenly Wu screams
in horror her eyes fixed on seven
decaying bodies slumped at a table the
scene early mirrors their first meal in
the initial tunnel but instead of fresh
food the table is Laden with maggot
infested rotting noodles hunger gnaws at
mnd driven to Madness by his craving he
grabs a green black Noodle and devours
it witnessing his desperation wuu offers
him a cracker when maen asks for more
she refuses emphasizing its importance
for her unborn child maen transformed
into a cold ruthless indiv idual pulls
out Kang's gun and threatens everyone to
hand over their food and obey his
commands their Journey resumes fueled by
the desperate search for an escape from
The Damp tunnel soon they stumble upon
another door leading them into a
familiar Dusty Red Room wiu notices
there is no secret passage behind the
calendar instead a collection of body
parts preserved in jars meanwhile Tang
becomes captivated by a skeleton adorned
in a beautiful traditional dress and
jewelry as if on Q the television
replays the agonizing image of the
drowning woman pleading for their help
with a deafening bang mawen shatters the
television silencing the woman's pleas
he coldly informs the group that he
knows how to find a way out lining them
up at gunpoint mawin Reveals His
chilling Theory the deaths of shen and
Kang coincided with the discovery of
exit ways from the previous tunnels he
believes another sacrifice is necessary
to unlock the next passage Kang
desperate to survive attempts to seduce
mawen but he cruy rejects her advances
noting her fading Beauty she flees to
the Red Room seeking makeup and the
ornaments on the skeleton meanwhile
mawin considers the autistic XU as his
next victim but chenia intervenes mawin
confronts Chen about the strange timer
on his wrist asking for its significance
Chen counters that the answer depends on
mawin himself sparking a fight Chen
gains the upper hand and disarms mawen
holding the gun Chen demands that mawen
tell him more about the murder story
that he told the bus driver earlier
mawin reveals a chilling detail a
mysterious voice whispered the story to
him while he slept on the
he refuses to reveal the ending fearing
its horror desperate maen grabs A Shard
of glass and holds it to Wu's throat
forcing Chen to surrender the gun back
in control the increasingly psychotic
mawen orders a heavily pregnant wuu to
shoot Chen inflicting a shoulder wound a
chilling laugh escapes ma win's lips as
he is about to whisper the story's end
into Chen as ear moments before his
demise however Z the teenager intervenes
with a swift strike to the back of his
head despite the hit mawin remains
unfaced and drags Zia by the neck into
the Red Room Tang oblivious to the
struggle continues applying makeup
unconcerned by the brutal scene
unfolding before her suddenly J pushes
Maan away prompting him to point his gun
at the teenager in a fit of rage Zia
bravely questions his masculinity
further fueling his anger without
hesitation mawen shoots Zia silencing
her forever possessed by an unknown
Force Tang rises from her vanity table
and stabs mawen with a hidden sword
taking the gun she andj deliver the
final blow ensuring his death as
expected a secret passage opens not
behind the calendar but behind the
Wardrobe this leads them to the fourth
tunnel an eerie Place filled with
strange lights barbed wire and
mannequins as Wu goes into labor ju
stays by her side meanwhile chenia and
Tang armed with the gun and one bullet
left search the bus parked in the tunnel
suddenly Tang spots a seemingly alive
mawin outside and panics stepping out of
the bus she fires her final Bullet at a
shadowy figure mistaking it for mawen
screaming in Terror she runs through the
the tunnel stumbling upon numerous dead
bodies of mawen duplicates of the man
she thought she killed lost and
desperate she finds herself in a dark
room with only an antique makeup drawer
for company as she sits before the
mirror a pair of unseen hands emerge
from the darkness and swiftly slit her
throat ending her life wyu gives birth
but sadly the baby does not survive Chen
juu and wuyu the remaining survivors
enter the fifth tunnel Lush Greenery
fills the tunnel and a door stands
visible in the distance as they approach
the egg it wuyu unexpectedly stabs
chenia with a knife the green leaves
around them turn brown and the timer on
Chen's watch reaches zero as he falls to
the ground fading from the tunnel chenia
finds himself waking up in a medical
laboratory surrounded by machines he
realizes the terrifying events he
experienced were merely a dream the only
real event was the murder of the
hitchiker at the movie's beginning the
next scene reveals more details as
police officers discuss the murder two
days ago serial killer xiangu fleeing
the police suffered a horrific accident
near the jinpen mountain tunnel and
slipped into a coma JW is a sadistic
murderer who kidnapped six married women
torturing and killing five of them he
then cut off their ring fingers and used
them as fishing bait the sixth victim
according to police reports is still
alive using gathered Clues the police
deduce that the sixth victim is held
captive in a cave near the Zang shuy
River however bad weather threatens to
flood all nearby caves jeopardizing the
victim's life in desperation the police
turned to Leading psychotherapist ch Gia
they asked him to use a medical
experiment to enter the subconscious of
the Kos jangu hoping to locate the sixth
victim the shocking truth is revealed
the sixth victim is none other than
Chen's own wife the experiment's first
phase concludes and the next begins in
24 hours during this time Chen delves
deeper into the mind of the murderer
Jang XU he learns that xu's mother was
an Unfaithful actress and his father a
Salesman was often absent consumed by
alcohol and fishing on July 15th 1996
Jew's mother murdered his father Chen
then decodes the symbolic meaning of the
tunnel and its inhabitants the tunnel
represents Jew's subconscious and the
passengers symbolize different aspects
of his personality the insurance
salesman embodies his father while the
woman in red and heavy makeup reflects
his mother changia represents Jew's
rational scientific and social side
while Kang the driver embodies his
violent impulses and hints of his
mother's lover the pregnant woman
represents his super ego showcasing an
ideal mother hopeful caring and loving
meanwhile the siblings JW and Zia embody
his childhood selves one weak and
interested in space and maths the other
effeminate when chenjia joined them in
the tunnel he aimed to help zuu Escape
his subconscious and return to reality
he even placed a map directly before
xu's rational side hoping it would guide
them out however with the demise of the
rational Persona xu's subconscious
plunged into chaos trapped in an endless
loop analyzing the personalities he
encountered Shen concludes that one
among them Harbors a murderous intent
lurking in the shadows and claiming the
lives of the others one by one time is
of the essence so Chen Dives back into
Jang xu's subconscious determined to
find his wife before the experiment
second phase Begins the doctor warns
Chen to limit his interactions with the
real je to avoid being influenced Chan
immerses himself once more in the depths
of xu's mind this time he confronts the
real zuu directly demanding information
about the missing sixth woman instead of
a straightforward answer zuu launches
into a rambling monologue about his
hatred for women fueled by their
supposed infidelity leaving him behind
Chen Ventures deeper where he finds the
autistic teenager zuu trapped in a cage
to his surprise Zia the effeminate side
of jiang's Personality also emerges
despite being killed earlier in the bus
travel Chen dces that Zia is the evil
side who has been killing other
personalities within Jang in response
Zia sarcastically claps on solving the
mystery Chen further adds that
witnessing his cheating mother murder
his father as a child has instilled in
Jang a negative perception of all women
this Twisted perception fuels his desire
to kidnap torture and kill married women
teenage zuu attempts to distance himself
from Zia declaring his desire to grow up
alone and his hatred for killing he
tries to Aid Chen in locating the sixth
victim using his Rubik's Cube but Zia
drags him deeper into the darkness Chen
gives Chase experiencing a montage of
traumatic events from xu's childhood he
ultimately finds himself in a theatrical
room of fear sitting in the audience
alongside teenage Shu they watches a
mysterious figure dressed in black
emerges from behind the curtain as the
doctor had worn Chen this figure is an
alternate version of Chen himself
seeping into and merging with xu's
subconscious this dark and menacing
version of Chen is shaped by the
gruesome criminal cases he has
encountered throughout his career this
dark Persona reveals that it was him the
evil Chen that influenced teenage youu
into killing the other passengers within
the tunnel he orders you to kill Chen
once more however drawing upon his
expertise as a psychotherapist Chen
intervenes showcasing the true love of a
mother figure thereby halting Jew's
murderous intent Chen then guides the
lost and frighten Jew toward the
tunnel's exit as a result of Chen's
actions the real older Xiang XU awakens
in the laboratory he reveals to the
police the precise location of Chen's
wife leading to her rescue just moments
before she drowns that now Chen must
fight his evil alter ego and win if he
fails to do so the evil Alter Ego will
take over his body Chen defeats his evil
side again and again and every time the
evil side simply stands up fresh as he
was in the start seeing no other way
Chen grabs the pistol he had been hiding
and shoots his own head killing his evil
alter ego but slipping into coma himself
as the movie ends we see a bittersweet
ending Chen seemingly healthy is walking
inside a tunnel when a bus stops near
him